Kansas has become the first state to
pass a bill that defines women as
someone who is biologically born female
that's it that's what a woman is
which means that this will ban men who
identify as transgender women from using
single sex areas designated for women
it's called the women's Bill of Rights
it was approved by legislators 26 to 10
on Thursday only Republican support
there and the bill defines a female as
someone quote whose biological
reproductive system is developed to
produce OVA while male refers to anyone
whose reproductive system is developed
to fertilize the OVA of a female this is
a beautiful bill because
it it doesn't just say don't trans the
kids
it doesn't just say wait till eight
to introduce kids to transgenderism in
schools once they turn nine that's fine
it doesn't just say only miners can't
it's it Bans transgenderism